internet and citizens of reject nation welcome
back to another exciting episode of koi's comic
corner i am slightly healed the voice is coming
back i am no longer quite the voice of doom but
slightly the voice of doom this episode is very
special because we're going to talk about the
entirety of phase five going into six and
how i think victor von doom is going to be
implemented in a number of these properties and
in fact the big bad not necessarily kang but dr
doom pulling a lot of strings we're gonna get to
all of that but before we do please like leave a
comment subscribe let us know you love us i want
to read these comments i've been enjoying them
and speaking of which a lot of you asked about
these shirts the tie-dye shirts i wear box lunch
gifts the good folks at box lunch clad me in this
beautiful ware tell him i sent you and speaking of
amazing comments i've been enjoying reading thank
you to everyone who has followed me on tik tok
you guys have been amazing there's 15 second to
three minute videos over there a lot like what
i do here but in bite size little morses if you
think 20 minutes is too long you got 20 second
options get on over to my tick tock and thank
you to everyone who has alright let's get into it
so before we get into doom himself kevin feige
has confirmed that fantastic four is in fact not
an origin story and that ties beautifully into how
i think they're going to implement doom because i
think honestly doom is our way into the fantastic
four and i think that is really interesting we've
seen lots and lots of these movies where
the heroes bring us the villain we haven't
really seen a villain bring us heroes and i think
those origins are gonna be tied together really
beautifully and we're gonna be laying a lot of
seeds throughout an entire phase in the beautiful
way that we had thanos set up through post-credit
scenes through little easter eggs through tie-ins
leading up to getting him an infinity war let's go
the other way let's use dr doom to lead us towards
the kickoff of phase six with fantastic four now
how do i think we'll get there first of all we get
the knowledge that there is likely and this is a
rumor for now but we'll see a post-credit scene
featuring doctor doom in wakanda forever that
film is out this year that is the conclusion
of phase four what better way to conclude a phase
than by kicking off your new villain you have a
post-credits scene you set up through the film it
looks like we're going to have two nations at war
we've got the wakandans against the atlanteans so
it looks like we're going to have a lot of really
the trailer good god we're gonna have a lot of
stunning imagery between these two rival nations
but if you're expanding the world geopolitically
if you're making something as politically savvy
as the first black panther or further you're gonna
have other nations and what better way to bring in
doom than by having doom look at the weakness of
whatever culture he's seeing what what snarky way
to have him introduce them by saying like oh these
people have fallen it's time for me to you know
use my power or just a commentary on all of these
meta humans these overpowered beings clashing i
think latveria is introduced at the very end of
black panther and i think our post-credits scene
setting up phase five is doom that's the rumor
that's how i do it i do think black panther is the
absolute best way to bring in everything in the
geopolitical landscape to come now from there
we're kicking off phase five with quantum mania
this is a great way to kick off phase 5 because
our phase 5 villain does look to be kang now i
think our multiverse villain is going to be doom
now when you have your phase 5 villain with kang
you're you're introducing him after he's been
soft introduced as he who remains we've
met jonathan majors he who remains in loki
we saw comic accurate imagery of kang but we
haven't met him yet all of the speeches that
beautiful shakespearean delivery in episode six
of loki was about how he's not the worst of them
he's protected them he's arguably the good
guy of the kangs we're about to meet the real
kang in ant-man quantomania now i was fortunate
enough to see the ant-man trailer in hall h we do
see kang in all of his glory and he is powerful
he is intimidating and i think throughout quantum
mania this is a film that takes place largely
in the quantum realm we're gonna see a lot more
time elements we're gonna see a lot more reality
and time manipulation which is what kang is about
which is going to set the precedent for
where phase 5 goes but throughout that
i think we're going to be having slight hints
at doom or someone that might be working with
kang i think sometimes in the comics doom and kang
are simpatico for their greater good i think where
kang controls time doom might control space as
in physical land i think these two are going
to be collaborative and i'm not sure if doom
will physically show up in quantum mania but i
would almost guarantee elements of quantum mania
will relate to doctor doom as we kick off phase
five now secret invasion this is our big paranoid
thriller this one is a tv show that looks like the
most espionage elements of winter soldier bringing
us back to that grounded reality what better way
to worry about the world being invaded by aliens
and the paranoia of are our heroes who we say they
are than by bringing in a dictator i think this is
the first time we see him again i think after the
post-credits scene we might now again see doom in
his full glory i don't know how much screen time i
don't know how big of a presence but i think while
we're seeing the world expand as we're seeing the
not just new york we're no longer in phase one
as we're seeing everything in the mcu get more
and more global i think a great way to show
lavaria again and a great way to show the power
that doom wheeled setting just again we're still
at like level one of breadcrumbs using doom as
in i would do that differently as doom being a
certain element of power and terror at a faraway
land again as this expands to a worldwide secret
invasion so now we've met doom two maybe three
times at this point and that's great because it's
a lot like the comic books a lot of the time doom
is pulling the strings from behind doors and
he's in a few frames but his presence is felt the
important thing about doom is that he's just so
imposing and he's got a nest for lack of a better
term he is always authoritative and terrifying
now i think we get to see where he comes from i
personally would utilize his mother in the agatha
show his mother was a witch the powerful thing
about doom is he's as smart as reed but he also
wields magic there's a lot of superheroes that are
very overpowered but magic is there for lack of a
better term krypt tonight doom wields both science
and magic if you remember back to thor thor is
talking about how magic is just science you can't
explain yet i think agatha brings that to play
we've got chaos magic already established in
one division we've got what corruption that does
already established what if doom and doom's mother
wield a form of chaos magic what if agatha knows
doom's mama what if all of that comes in here
and we see the birth of the concept of victor von
doom if not victor von doom as a child himself
launching us through time bringing us to adult
doom in a more established way by this point in
phase five now here we are with new world order
the world distrusts heroes because of secret
invasion and because of the things i think set
up and miss marvel with the department of damage
control leading to thunderbolt the world doesn't
know what to do with this new era of hero now in
the sam wilson captain america comic books people
don't like sam wilson wielding the shield much
like trolls on the internet don't like sam wilson
wielding the shield we live in a tempestuous world
in our reality and in the mcu's reality people
like to let chaos weaken nation people like to let
instability cause rifts in power i think doom
maybe not as much as he's an agatha but i think
doom might be implementing here as someone that's
trying to use the weakness of a world fighting
itself which i do think is going to come into
play in new world order and i don't think it's a
coincidence that this film leads into thunderbolts
i think the events at the end of new world order
with an instability with a nation fighting itself
with a rivalry between heroes and the public all
of these things it's time for doom to want to take
over power and i think there's going to be a lot
of elements of him between this and thunderbolts
and from there from thunderbolts i think we go
right into fantastic four now the thunderbolts
are a bunch of heroes that are actually villains
they're playing as heroes to manipulate the public
i'm wondering if doom will literally be the norman
osborne of this world what if instead of norman
osborn a sony character that has often led the
thunderbolts what if it's literally a villain
manipulating things now we do have baron zemo
and baron zemo is the original leader of the
thunderbolts i would actually prefer they use
baron zemo i think daniel bruhl is fantastic but
if they don't doom's a cool option now as far as
fantastic four we now know it's not an origin
movie so we're going from thunderbolts ending
the phase five into fantastic four kicking off
as of now as of what we know phase six what if
that conclusion what if that cliffhanger is
an avengers level event as the phases have so
far ended and then we kick off with things in
disarray things in chaos what if doom has met
the fantastic four because he was scarred in the
accident that caused them but we meet them through
knowing more about this character than them
now we might throughout phase five meet sue or
reed or even human torture ben graham there's
rumors that ben grimm is popping up very soon
but if we've got sprinkles of them leading up to
their team-up movie that's a better way to build
them like the avengers right like remember
we had individual movies of these characters
then the avengers what if we meet them and
we kind of sympathize with doom what if
there's some empathy for this character because
we've met him as a child in agatha because we
we see how he wants to rule his kingdom we maybe
even see how his people love them now obviously
he's a fascist he's a dictator but that hasn't
stopped americans from loving dictators before
you heard me that might be the interesting way
to go into fantastic four with some empathy for
doom being conflicted by the fantastic four in
their first team movie and that brings us to
the kang dynasty now this phase i've focused on
doom there's gonna be a lot of kang in it too
but i'm focusing on doom for this video and that's
important for this movie i think with kang dynasty
we've basically had two villains running
things in phase five and that's really fun
if that's accurate i think it's gonna be a really
interesting way to differentiate the multiverse
saga from the infinity saga because we've had a
phase five lead kang but now a phase six lead doom
and i think while the dynasty of kang is running
through time chasing his love manipulating reality
by way of time travel and causing havoc throughout
centuries of problems for centuries of different
adventures i think the way the kang dynasty ends
is that what we thought might happen at the end
of loki with the tva and everything exploding
what if reality itself can't handle the amount
of manipulation that kang has caused what if the
avengers have failed to an even greater level than
they failed in infinity war what if reality as
we know it breaks and the only person that can
keep reality together is doom using science and
magic and those fantastic four that we just met
can't be the heroes they need to be doom is the
hero keeping the world together and bringing us
two secret wars our villain is also a hero because
he wants to rule everything and he becomes the
giant multiversal king of this entire phase four
five and six ruling secret wars now secret wars
i'm going to be brief because we could do we could
do 10 videos on secret but i think secret wars is
going to be a series of elements that take place
in shattered realities i think all of the people
that wanted multiverse of madness to be fox
and sony and different continuity they might
get that with secret oars and i think all of that
is going to be held together like in the comics
with battle world by dr doom now doctor doom is a
very powerful character i don't know what that's
going to mean with manipulating these realities
as far as what he wields but that's why i think
there's going to be a kang and doom element
leading to this and that's why i think secret
oars might be literally the biggest movie of all
time as far as in this genre i've been saying it
for a little bit that i think where end game and
infinity war were the culmination of phases one
through three i honestly think secret wars is the
culminations of one through six not just four five
and six i think kang dynasty is basically four
five and six i think sears is one through six
and i think our biggest bad today may just be a
character that comic fans have wanted for years to
be handled correctly i think we're about to meet
him and i think we're about to be terrified of him
throughout this phase through many different
properties for years to come i think it's about
to be doom season and i cannot wait all right
chill lovelies these are just theories this is
conjecture this is all for breeding way too many
comic books read some comic books if you want to
know which comic books i would recommend for doom
check out the doom video on this very channel i
did a whole breakdown of who i'd cast as doom why
doom's important all of those elements and those
are still going to be in my comic recommendations
i love giving you guys comic book wrecks
please do check those out and i promise in the
next video i'll give you some fresh new ones but
in the meantime please do like subscribe leave a
comment this video was because a bunch of you said
we want to see his doom video i am listening i am
reading those and i do appreciate all the love you
you rejects are lovely so thank you for having
me here uh thank you for sharing this video i'm
seeing these views go up and it means the world
also you guys are watching a [__] ton of this
like a lot of it i see the length and it makes
me so happy please go tell your local comic book
store you love them tell your mom give her
a hug appreciate you guys i'll see you soon